[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend der
Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine war in
vieler Hinsicht ein wegruf während der
deutsche Wirtschaftsminister letztes
Jahr über den Globus jettete um hastig
Gas einzukaufen wo er es nur herkriegen
konnte richteten sich die Augen auch
noch auf einen anderen Elefanten im Raum
China was wenn es mit dieser Diktatur
auch zu einem plötzlichen Abbruch der
Beziehungen käme im Vergleich dazu war
wirtschaftlich gesehen dass
Russlandgeschäft gerade zu Peanuts ein
solches Szenario etwa wenn China Taiwan
über viele wäre natürlich der Extremfall
aber die Sorgen beginnen schon weit
unterhalb dieser Schwelle und es gibt
sie schon lange heute veröffentlichte
die Bundesregierung ihre neue China
Strategie für die sie allerdings erst
mal eine gemeinsame Haltung finden
musste Andrea Maurer berichtet
es ist ein Termin wie am Reißbrett
entworfen um über die neue
china-strategie zu sprechen das hier
sind Außenministerin und
Wirtschaftsminister beim Chip Hersteller
Infinion das Dax-Unternehmen macht einen
Großteil seines Umsatzes in China und
investiert nun Milliarden schwer in ein
neues Werk in Dresden
das geht dabei eben nicht in dieser
china-strategie darum dass wir uns
abkoppeln sondern dass wir uns
diversifizieren in vielen ist ein
Weltkonzern sie haben ein Großteil ihres
Umsatzes auch in China und rightley so
das muss auch so sein denn wir wollen ja
den Handel intensivieren aber wir dürfen
eben auch nicht naiv sein Deutschland
ist abhängig von China seine Markt
seinen Rohstoffen seinen Antibiotika
Deutschland soll unabhängiger werden von
China das immer autoritäre Auftritt
seinen Einfluss ausbaut militärisch
aufrüstet
Deutschlands China Strategie heißt die
risking wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeiten
verringern ohne Beziehungen zu kappen
das nimmt die Industrie in die Pflicht
die zeigt zurück auf die Politik
zunächst der Satz wäre die risking
möchte von China muss den Standort
Deutschland stärken den Standort
Deutschland und Europa Stärken ich
glaube dass das ein Punkt ist der viel
zu oft untergeht also das heißt wer hat
gegenüber China auftreten möchte sollte
darüber nachdenken ob eigentlich das
Standard Deutschland und Europa gerade
attraktiv ist lange hat die Regierung um
ihre China Strategie gerungen SPD
Kanzler im Team Vorsicht und
Wirtschaftsinteressen grüne
Außenministerin im Team Härte und Werte
zusammen vorgestellt haben sie die
geeinte china-strategie heute nicht die
Außenministerin nutzt ein Pendel am
Mittag reicht nicht sagt die Union diese
Strategie die muss ins Parlament die
muss ins Blähungen des Deutschen
Bundestages und zwar mit allen Ressorts
auch da muss der Bundeskanzler zugegen
sein da muss die Außenministerin da sein
der Wirtschaftsminister der
Finanzminister des betrifft alle
Ressorts schon im November war ein
erster strategieentwurf des
Außenministeriums bekannt geworden der
vor chinesischen Investitionen in Hessen
wandte den Kanzler hat das nicht
abgehalten die Minderheitsbeteiligung
des chinesischen Staatskonzerns kosko an
einem Hamburger Hafen Terminal
durchzusetzen in der china-strategie
jetzt kein Wort mehr zu helfen aber die
Ansage kritische Abhängigkeiten künftig
zu vermeiden wir stellen Deutschland
breiter auf diversifizieren unsere
lieber und die Versorgung mit wichtigen
Rohstoffen
sie kennen dabei unsere Devise die
risking und nicht die katling der
chinesische Botschafter reagiert heute
schnell und scharf
zwanghaftes die resking auf der
Grundlage von ideologischen Vorurteilen
und wettbewerbsangst ist nur
kontraproduktiv und verschärft die
Risiken künstlich
83 Wochen hat die Regierung an der
china-strategie gearbeitet auch ins
Chinesische Mandarin soll sie jetzt
übersetzt werden aber China hat wohl
schon verstanden dass ich was ändert
das wollen wir noch vertiefen mit einer
China-Experte mit der
Politikwissenschaftlerin Janka Oertel
sie leitet als Direktorin das
asienprogramm des European Council und
von relations und ihr
Forschungsschwerpunkt sind Chinas
Beziehungen zu Europa und den USA guten
Abend
wir haben es gehört China Ernte ändert
sich was aber durch dieses
Strategiepapier der Regierung schwebt ja
auch dieser dieses Grundgefühl dass ich
vor allem in China einiges geändert hat
in den letzten Jahren wie nehmen sie das
war wie analysieren Sie das in der Tat
also das ist glaube ich die Grund
Prämisse die man in diesem Papier auch
ablesen kann wir nehmen zur Kenntnis
dass sich die Realität verändert hat das
ist ein anderes China ist mit dem
Deutschland umgehen muss und dass ich
deshalb eben auch die Beziehung
Deutschlands zu China verändern müssen
aber dass ich deswegen auch ganz viel
bei uns verändern muss er das in
Deutschland und in Europa Hausaufgaben
anstehen dafür wieder zukünftige Umgang
mit China gestaltet werden kann die hat
sich denn China verändert was hat sich
vor allem verändert
aggressiver nach außen im Auftreten
deutlich aggressiver auch nach innen im
Auftreten restriktiver wesentlich
stärkerer Fokus auf Kontrolle auf
Sicherheit und einen wesentlich
geringerer Fokus auf eine freie
Marktwirtschaft auf Bedingungen die auch
für deutsche und europäische Konzerne
attraktiv sind das gab ja vor ein paar
Tagen hat der britische
geheimdienstausschuss des Unterhauses in
London seine Regierung sogar
ausdrücklich gewarnt da sei mal immer
noch viel zu naiv weil China alles
mögliche vorhabe Baupläne stehlen Europa
unter Beobachtung und den
wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeit treiben ja
es ist ein ganz klarer Vorgabe der
chinesischen Regierung die
Abhängigkeiten anderer Staaten von China
zu vergrößern und dabei gleichzeitig die
eigenen Abhängigkeiten zu verringern und
das wird mit allen Mitteln
vorangetrieben Lauterer und nicht so
Lauterer Art und darauf muss ich
Deutschland und Europa einstellen denn
der Wettbewerb hier ist hart und die
Realität die systemische Rivalität steht
im Vordergrund auch von chinesischer
Seite denn von chinesischer Seite wird
die risking schon ganz lange betrieben
und sogar auch die kapling vorangebracht
also entkommen woran lässt sich das
ablesen es wird wir können ganz klar
sehen dass ich auch die ja die
Handelsbeziehungen zwischen uns und
China schon jetzt in Richtung China
verschieben also dass der Export nach
China nach unten geht dass der Import
aus China steigt und dass unsere
Abhängigkeiten wachsen während Chinas
Abhängigkeiten sinken und das ist eine
ganz klare strategische Vorgabe der
chinesischen Regierung sind ganz klare
strategische Prämisse die sich dort die
dort vorgegeben wurde aber brauchen die
Chinesen uns dann nicht auch ich meine
Europa ist ja nun auch ein ein
wohlstandsmarkt das ist eindeutig so ähm
china möchte gerne mit Europa weiter
Handel treiben aber unter chinesischen
Bedingungen und eben nicht unter
Bedingungen die von Europa diktiert
werden das heißt wenn hier in der China
Strategie davon gesprochen wird dass wir
auf einen level playing field setzen
dass wir darauf setzen dass unsere
Beziehung sind also gleichwertig sind
dann ist das ganz explizit etwas was die
chinesische Regierung nicht möchte das
heißt da müssen wir uns ganz klar
darüber sein wie viel Wunschdenken da
bei uns auch dabei ist davon was
eigentlich noch möglich ist mit China
der Zeit
ist das ja das eine ist jetzt sozusagen
der Blick aus der Vogelperspektive das
strategische aber das andere ist wie
viel Arbeitsplätze hierzulande auf dem
Spiel stehen oder wie ganze Unternehmen
ja womöglich in die Knie gehen dann
plötzlich das China Geschäft massiv
eingeschränkt würde also da muss man nur
an den Autobauer wie VW denken ich
glaube da gibt es zahlen das vier von
zehn Neuwagen inzwischen in China dort
verkauft werden ich glaube plötzlich ist
ein ganz guter Begriff den sie da
verwendet haben denn plötzlich wäre
tatsächlich ein Problem was wir aber
sehen ist ja tatsächlich das durch die
Vorgaben der chinesischen Regierung
schon jetzt der Markt in China für viele
Konzerne kleiner wird dass sie aus dem
Markt verdrängt werden dass wir eben im
Telekommunikationssektor oder im
Windbereich keine Rolle mehr spielen
jetzt für den chinesischen Markt selber
das heißt es ein Prozess der sowieso
vonstatten gehen wird diesen zu managen
und diesen strategisch zu behandeln also
von europäischer Seite auch zu gestalten
dass es sicherlich die Aufgabe jetzt
eben nicht auf ein plötzliches
entkoppeln setzen zu müssen in einem
Falle eines Konfliktes wie sie es auch
eingangs genannt haben
das weiß man natürlich nicht ob so das
passiert aber das Interessante ist ja
auch das wenn man jetzt mal diesen alten
Slogan denkt Wandel durch Handel der
sich nun ja ziemlich irgendwie dieser
woiert hat dass eben auch Russland
entgegen seiner wirtschaftlichen
Interessen dann trotzdem in einen Krieg
eingetreten ist genau es geht eben nicht
mehr darum dass wir bei der chinesischen
Führung darauf setzen können dass die
wirtschaftlichen Ziele über allem stehen
dass es um wohlstandsvermehrung geht das
ist immer darum geht sozusagen
chinesische Wirtschaft vorne anzustellen
sondern es geht ganz klar und politische
Interessen die im Vordergrund stehen und
dann muss die Wirtschaft im Zweifel auch
hinten anstehen
danke für die Expertise und das Gespräch
sehr gerne vielen Dank
man darf davon ausgehen dass China sich
sehr genau ansieht wie erfolgreich oder
erfolglos die Russen ihren Krieg in der
Ukraine führen und wie der Westen sich
dazu verhält auch deshalb war es den
NATO Mitgliedern wichtig vom Gipfel in
Vilnius ein Zeichen der Geschlossenheit
zu senden zum Auftakt hat das ja nicht
funktioniert die Ukraine zeigten sich
sehr enttäuscht über die ausgebliebene
beitrittseinladung am Ende konnte
selenski aber zumindest mit einem doch
ziemlich dicken Paket von langfristigen
zusagen und neuen Waffenlieferungen nach
Hause reisen während er bei der NATO war
stand hier wieder unter Beschuss die
letzte Nacht war besonders heftig daran
berichtet aus Kiew
20 Drohnen und zwei Marschflugkörper hat
Russland allein die letzte Nacht auf
Kiew geschossen am Tag danach wirkt die
ukrainische Hauptstadt so als sei der
Krieg weit weg dieser Eindruck verfliegt
wenn man mit den Menschen spricht die
Luftangriffe und der NATO-Gipfel sind
bestimmende Themen
wir haben uns an die Luftangriffe
gewöhnt und weil es einen Gipfel gab
habe ich mit diesen Angriffen gerechnet
ich persönlich bin sehr enttäuscht weil
ich erwartet habe dass man uns konkrete
Schritte ankündigen würde
ein Zeitplan mehr zahlen genauere Pläne
es ist zu früh für uns um der NATO
beizutreten das geht nur nach dem Krieg
aber dann nach seinem Ende müssen wir
definitiv und schnell in die NATO
diesmal hat die Luft da wären Kiew alle
russischen Drohnen und Raketen
abgeschossen doch es gibt keinen Schutz
gegen herabstürzende Trümmerteile diese
Kieler Wohnung ist ausgebrannt niemand
starb aber vier Menschen wurden verletzt
und viele Anwohner hier hatten
Todesangst
zuerst waren der Explosionen mehr wie
Schüsse oder sowas ich schaffte es nur
die Kinder im Badezimmer zu verstecken
und dann kam die Explosion
rein körperlich schafften wir es nicht
mehr runter und blieben im Bad
Ivan hatte nur die Abschüsse der
ukrainischen Luftabwehr gehört es
erschrecke in fast sagt er wie
selbstverständlicher heute wieder seine
Arbeit nachgeht die Ergebnisse des
Nato-Gipfels und die Art wie der Westen
Waffen liefert ergeben für ihn jedoch
ein stimmiges Bild
in letzter Zeit sieht es danach aus als
wäre Europa etwas Kriegs müde um uns
ausreichend Munition zu liefern sie
geben uns im Moment gerade genug damit
wir nicht verlieren aber nicht genug
damit wir die Oberhand gewinnen sie
verstehen nicht dass nur der Sieg der
Ukraine über Russland diesen Krieg
beenden und neue Kriege in Europa
verhindern wird
für einen Friedensvertrag Territorium
abtreten das lehnen laut Umfragen über
80% der Ukraine weiterhin ab dafür
nehmen sie ein Leben im Krieg in Kauf
Das temporär so friedlich aussehen kann
über den NATO-Gipfel redet nachher auch
Maybrit Illner mit ihren Gästen das sind
unter anderem der künftige Botschafter
in Moskau Graf Lamsdorf und der
afd-politiker gauland
vom NATO-Gipfel ist Joe Biden weiter
nach Finnland gereist der letzte Besuch
eines US-Präsidenten in Helsinki ist
fünf Jahre her damals traf sich dort
Donald Trump mit Vladimir Putin und
verkündete danach er vertraue dem
russischen Präsidenten nicht weniger als
seinen eigenen US-Geheimdiensten
und mit dem Besuch heute geht es bei dir
jetzt weiter Hans ja der Versicherte der
jetzige US-Präsident Joe Biden dass die
USA weiterhin ein verlässlicher Partner
in der NATO bleiben der seit Aprilia
auch Finnland als neuestes Mitglied
angehört bei einem Treffen mit
Präsidentin Helsinki betonte beiden den
Zusammenhalt er glaube nicht dass die
NATO jemals stärker gewesen sein
anschließenden Gipfel mit den Staat und
Regierungschefs der weiteren nordischen
Länder Schweden Dänemark Norwegen und
Island ging es auch um die
Zusammenarbeit beim Klimaschutz
Kriege bewaffnete Konflikte
Preissteigerungen und der Klimawandel
haben die globale Ernährungslage
verschärft das erklärte die
Welthungerhilfe bei der Vorstellung
ihres Jahresberichts 2022
welthungerhilfepräsidentin Thieme wie es
aber auch auf internationale
Zielsetzungen hin mit denen man eine
gute Strategie habe um den Hunger
langfristig zu überwinden es brauche
jetzt den politischen Willen und die
Einigkeit die nötigen Maßnahmen auch
umzusetzen laut den Vereinten Nationen
litten im Jahr 2022 weltweit rund 735
Millionen Menschen an Hunger
die Bundesregierung will die Anpassung
an den Klimawandel vorantreiben das
Kabinett hat ein Gesetz auf den Weg
gebracht dass den Rahmen dafür bilden
soll es geht um Vorsorgemaßnahmen auf
allen Verwaltungsebenen um etwa auf
Wetterextreme wie Hitze Dürre oder
Starkregen besser vorbereitet zu sein
die heutigen Protestaktionen der
klimaschutzgruppe letzte Generation an
den Flughäfen Hamburg und Düsseldorf
sind parteiübergreifend scharf
kritisiert worden und haben eine Debatte
ausgelöst wie Flughäfen besser geschützt
werden können
bundesinnenministerin Phaser kündigte an
es werde demnächst tatsächliches
Standards für die Betreiber kritischer
Infrastruktur geben am Morgen hatten
Aktivisten an beiden Airports
Zaunanlagen überwunden und die Start-
und Landebahnen blockiert insgesamt
mussten mehr als 50 Flüge gestrichen
werden
psychische Erkrankungen und
Verhaltensstörungen waren 2021 bei
Kindern und Jugendlichen die häufigste
Ursache für eine stationäre Behandlung
im Krankenhaus das teilt heute der
Statistische Bundesamt mit insgesamt
wurden
81.000 10 bis 17-Jährige wegen
psychischer Probleme in der Klinik
behandelt das sind sprach 19 Prozent
aller Krankenhausbehandlungen in dieser
Altersgruppe am häufigsten wurden
Depressionen diagnostiziert gefolgt von
psychischen Erkrankungen im Zusammenhang
mit Alkoholkonsum
na wenn Umfrageergebnisse oder
Sozialstudien offenbaren wie weit
verbreitet antidemokratisches
extremistisches Gedankengut und
geschichts Vergessenheit sind er klingt
ja die Forderung nach mehr Bildung wenn
das Elternhaus als wertevermittler
offenbar ausfällt dann müsste das doch
wenigstens die Schule leisten aufklären
bilden und auch klar aufzeigen wo in
dieser Gesellschaft der meinungskorridor
endet gegen Hitlerbilder im klassenchat
etwa muss die Lehrerschaft doch wohl
konsequent vorgehen nur sagt sich das
offenbar leichter als es getan ist je
nach Umfeld Anna Beyer berichtet über
einen Fall in Brandenburg der inzwischen
auch bundesweit Aufsehen erregt
Burgen Spreewald diese Botschaft hat ein
Ziel Lehrer einzuschüchtern die sich
gegen Rechtsextremismus an dieser Schule
engagieren die beiden Pädagogen hatten
vor zwei Monaten bekannt gemacht was ich
offenbar an ihrer Schule abspielt
Hakenkreuze an den Wänden rassistische
und homophobe Symbole im klassenchat
Schüler die ganz offen auf einem
Sportplatz in der Nähe mit Hitlergruß
posieren nun sagen die beiden Lehrer sie
fühlen sich in Burg nicht mehr sicher
sie lassen sich auf eigenen Wunsch
versetzen
beim Einkaufen in der Freistunde zum
Beispiel wo ich von zwei jungen
durchtrainierten
Erwachsenen ja schon massiv beleidigt in
der Öffentlichkeit du scheiß Zecke
verpiss dich aus Burg
ein Triumph für viele die so denken wie
der AFD Kreisvorsitzende er stört sich
schon lange am Engagement der Lehrer
diesen Post veröffentlichte er auf
Twitter bürgerliches Engagement wirkt
linksradikaler der Nutzern verlässt
Burger Schule
in der Region Burg und drumherum bis
nach Cottbus haben wir eine extrem gut
vernetzte eine sehr sehr aktive und
wahnsinnig gewaltbereite Rechtsextreme
organisierte Szene und die AFD ist
inzwischen einfach der parlamentarische
Armen dieser rechtsextremistisch sehen
in der Region wie polarisiert das Umfeld
der Schulenburg ist zeigt dieser offene
tief an die Schulleitung ein paar Eltern
von Schülerinnen und Schülern haben ihn
anonym verfasst sie fordern darin die
Entlassung der Lehrer ihre
Anschuldigungen seien haltlos es gibt
dazu keine Beweise keine bestätigten
Fakten und vor allem es ist nichts
passiert derweil halten die rechten
Parolen in den Klassenzimmern an ein
Schüler beschreibt die jetzige Situation
es hat sich im Gegenteil alles nur noch
verschlimmert und ich glaube dass das
mit der rückhaltlosigkeit zu tun hat die
die Lehrkräfte erfahren haben nach
wochenlanger Zurückhaltung äußert sich
der brandenburgische Bildungsminister
jetzt zu den Rechtsextremen Vorfällen
bin ein bisschen erschrocken verändert
ein bisschen an Zeiten die in
Deutschland eigentlich lange
Vergangenheit sein sollten und ich hoffe
sehr dass es gelingt dort in den
gesellschaftlichen Strukturen wieder zu
einem demokratischen Grundkonsens
zurückzufinden die beiden Pädagogen
hätten sich konkretere Maßnahmen und
eine eindeutige Positionierung gegen
rechts von den Behörden gewünscht
Händedruck brauchen wir nicht also
müssen die Probleme die wir hier in
Brandenburg haben speziell auch vor
allem in Südbrandenburg müssen wir halt
einfach ansprechen und auch wenn die
Landtagswahlen bevorstehen und die
Situation natürlich jetzt nicht so rosig
für die
Parteien abseits von der AFD Aussehen
mit dem Weggang der lehrerausburg geht
auch ein Stück Hoffnung im Kampf gegen
die Rechten Strukturen vor Ort verloren
die Methode ist nicht neu aber Russland
und Iran betreiben sie mit besonderem
Eifer als Staaten wohlgemerkt die
kidnappen und erpressen Geisel
diplomatie ist der zynische Begriff
dafür ein prominentes Beispiel aus
jüngster Zeit ist der Reporter des Wall
Street Journal der darauf hoffen muss
dass die US-Regierung Ihnen gegen einen
Russen eintauscht Joe Biden hat heute
angedeutet dass er zu einem solchen
Austausch auch bereit ist
auch mit ihrer Hand gibt es immer wieder
solche Deals allein in den letzten
Monaten wurden sechs politische
Häftlinge mit europäischer
Staatsangehörigkeit freigelassen Kamera
hat einen von ihnen getroffen
er ist wieder mit seiner Frau harika
vereint Kamera und gaderi österreichisch
iranischer Staatsbürger mehr als sieben
Jahre war er eine Geisel der Mullahs in
Iran
januar 2016 der IT-Berater ist auf einer
Geschäftsreise als er am Flughafen
Teheran verhaftet wird der Vorwurf
Spionage
kamerangeri kommt ins berüchtigte
erwin-gefängnis in Teheran in Einzelhaft
jetzt spricht der erstmals im Fernsehen
über seine Erlebnisse
die schlimmste was was ich erlebt habe
ist diese Hoffnungslosigkeit
die Tatsache dass man allein ist
und dass man geliefert ist und das ist
das ist das Schlimmste man hat keinen
Stolz keine würde und hundertprozentig
geliefert an an Sadisten
auch um sein Geständnis zu erzwingen
wochenlang weiß seine Frau nicht wo er
ist was er in der Hölle von Erwin wie er
es beschreibt erlebt lassen Bilder von
Misshandlungen anderer Gefangener dort
nur erahnen
[Musik]
zweimal habe ich mir gedacht sie bringen
mich zu einer Hinrichtung also sie haben
so getan als ob aber ohne das zu sagen
und diese zehn Minuten bis sie bis sie
herausstellt dass es alles nicht wahr
ist diese 10 Minuten ist dass wir ein
es ist unbeschreiblich es ist man kann
nicht sagen wie
zitternde Knie zitternde Stimme ja also
nicht einmal kommt man zu weinen so
schlimm ist das in dieser Zeit gibt ihm
seine Frau harika halt sie kämpft
gemeinsam mit
Menschenrechtsorganisationen für seine
Freilassung Kamera geht es im Gefängnis
immer schlechter seine
Überlebensstrategie er schreibt Bücher
gibt Deutschstunden die Spionage
Vorwürfe gegen ihn haben sich nie
bestätigt er ist sicher als Faust fand
benutzt worden zu sein für
Atomverhandlungen oder Gefangenen
austausche ich war ein Schachfigur in in
einem politischen Spiel zwischen Iran
und und westlichen Ländern
und ähm ich wurde sagen der Iran hat
sich hat als kaisernehmer agiert und und
willkürlich mich und die anderen
verhaftet um als als Schachfigur zu
nutzen die Verhandlungen
und tatsächlich kommen kamran-gadiri und
andere ausländische Geisen vor wenigen
Wochen frei im Austausch für den in
Belgien Verurteilten iranischen
Terroristen assadolor assadi assadi
wollte 2018 einen Anschlag auf die
iranische auslandsopposition in Paris
verüben der Plan wurde vereitelt zurück
in Wien findet Kamran gardiri kaum Ruhe
Schlaf und Essstörungen plagen ihn er
hat Schuldgefühle ich habe
bemerkt dass ich jetzt
vielleicht wie ein fremder Mann bin
wieder in der Familie
ich habe vieles verpasst genau die Zeit
wo die Kinder erwachsen geworden sind
ich habe verpasst in der Erziehung
mitzumachen ich habe verpasst meine Frau
zu trusten in schwierigen Zeiten das
alles will er jetzt nachholen Kamera ist
inzwischen in Therapie er wird noch
lange brauchen um die Jahre in der Hölle
von Erwin so wie es nennt zu verarbeiten
und jetzt noch mal Heinz Wolf mit
Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft die Zahl
der Firmen Pleiten in Deutschland ist
weiter gestiegen laut Statistischen
Bundesamt nimmt die Zahl schon seit fast
einem Jahr kontinuierlich zu welche
Gründe hat das von Bittmann ja vor allem
die schwächelnde Konjunktur setzt den
Betrieben zusehends mehr zu immer mehr
Unternehmen spüren jetzt da sind nach
Pandemie gestörten Lieferketten und
hohen Energiepreisen keine Reserven mehr
da und da die Zinsen stark angezogen
haben sind auf einmal die Kosten für
einen Überbrückungskredit auch nicht
mehr zu finanzieren und so bleibt dann
häufig nur noch der Weg zum Amtsgericht
so stieg die Zahl der
Unternehmensinsolvenz immer april um
14,4% im Vergleich zum Vorjahresmonat
auf
1428 besonders häufig melden sich
Betriebe aus dem Pflegebereich aus dem
Einzelhandel sowie aus der Bau und
Immobilienbranche zahlungsunfähig
und droht die Gefahr dass sich dieser
negative Trend fortsetzt ja darauf
deutet einen früh Indikator des
Statistischen Bundesamtes hin Fachleute
überrascht diese Entwicklung nicht
wirklich denn in der jüngeren
Vergangenheit hat der Staat kriselnden
Unternehmen immer wieder unter die Arme
gegriffen mit Hilfsgeldern vor allem
aber damit dass er teilweise
insolvenzantragspflichten ausgesetzt hat
mit dem Auslaufen dieser Unterstützungen
gelten nun wieder die alten Regeln und
es stellt sich schneller die
Zahlungsunfähigkeit ein Frank Bethmann
vielen Dank
in einer Woche beginnt in Australien und
Neuseeland die Frauenfußball
Weltmeisterschaft heute sind die
deutschen Nationalspielerinnen in ihrem
WM-Quartier angekommen nach mehr als 25
Stunden Reise ins Basislager nice Sydney
ging es für das Nationalteam von
Bundestrainerin von Tecklenburg direkt
auf den Trainingsplatz am 24 Juli
treffen die DFB Frauen im ersten
WM-Spiel auf Marokko zu sehen live hier
im ZDF
wer nach LA reist als Tourist der will
auch einmal in die Hills und diese
Buchstaben mit eigenen Augen sehen das
firmenlabel der Traumfabrik wobei es in
dieser Fabrik gerade ziemlich hoch
hergeht die Arbeitnehmer Strecken die
Drehbuchautoren haben schon von Monaten
aus Protest die Arbeit niedergelegt
jetzt folgen auch die Schauspieler die
aktuellen Verhandlungen zwischen
Filmstudios und Gewerkschaft über
Honorare und Arbeitskonditionen sind
vorhin gescheitert das wird dann jetzt
der erste Schauspieler Streik seit über
40 Jahren und das ausgerechnet im
Jubiläumsjahr
denn dieses Hollywood sein das feiert
sein hundertsten Geburtstag wie es
überhaupt entstand und welche
Geschichten sich darum ranken das
erzählt Claudio Armbruster
neun Buchstaben 100 Jahre
unzählbare träume und Tragödien
[Musik]
wie die von pack and whistle gefeiert am
New Yorker Broadway kam sie voller
Hoffnung nach Hollywood und scheiterte
im Herbst 1932 kletterte sie auf das
Haar und sprang in den Freitod seitdem
ist sie berühmt als das Hollywood sein
girl
[Musik]
1923 wurde das Zeichen gebaut ein
Werbegag sollte es sein für den
geplanten Wohnpark Hollywood Land der
dann doch nicht gebaut wurde aber die
Filmstadt Hollywood boomte ein Studio
nach dem anderen entstand und der
Werbegag wurde vier Buchstaben kürzer
gemacht zum Wahrzeichen für die
Traumfabrik
weil Wind und Wetter an ihm nackten
bekam es 1978 einen teuren Facelift die
Stars spendeten für neue Buchstaben
28.000 Dollar pro Stück der Rockmusiker
Alice Cooper kaufte ein neues o
playboy-chef you Hefner ein Y und so
weiter
[Musik]
als 1987 Papst Johannes Paul II zu
Besuch kam wurde aus Holly ein Hollywood
und dann auch noch das ein paar
marihuana-freunde machen aus dem
Hollywood ein Holly weed
vor ein paar Monaten wurde es frisch
gestrichen es soll hell erstrahlen im
Jubiläumsjahr das Zeichen unter dem
Filme Karrieren Träume und auch
Albträume entstanden
unter dem Harvey Weinstein
[Musik]
100 Jahre wird er heute alt dieser wohl
berühmteste und meist fotografierte
Schriftzug der Welt
und unsere Geschichte vom Anfang
angeblich wurde am Tage ihres Todes ein
Brief an packend was losgeschickt darin
das Angebot für eine Hauptrolle aber das
ist nur eine Hollywood Legende
aber natürlich eine filmreife das war es
von uns gleich geht's wie schon gesagt
bei madridinner weiter 030 gibt es dann
unsere heute schon mal Update mit nasant
aktivieren
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter eine regelrechte
Hitze Blase hat sich in der
Mittelmeerregion festgesetzt
Temperaturen von 30 bis 45 Grad sind bis
in die Mitte der kommenden Woche möglich
40 Grad und mehr durchaus in Spanien
Italien Griechenland und der Türkei und
ein Teil der Hitze erreicht uns
ebenfalls 37 Grad sind drin aber das nur
für ein Tag und das am Samstag in der
kommende Nacht gibt es etwas Regen im
Norden sonst klart es häufig auf die
Temperaturen gehen zurück auf 15 bis 10
Grad und der oft wiederholte Tipp lüften
Sie die Wohnung ordentlich durch damit
es tagsüber erträglicher wird und
tagsüber gibt es dann viel Sonnenschein
vor allem im Süden nach Norden den sind
die Wolken etwas dichter Richtung
Schleswig-Holstein tröpfelt es etwas aus
der Wolkendecke Temperaturen dazu
höchste Werte von 23 Grad ganz im Norden
und 31 Grad ganz im Südwesten ja am
Samstag erreicht uns dann eine Kaltfront
von Westen her und die kracht auf die
Hitze die vorher hier angesaugt wurde
Temperaturen bis 37 Grad sind drin und
diese Kaltfront überquert uns außerdem
in der Nacht auf Sonntag weiter ostwärts
am Sonntag ist es dann nicht mehr ganz
so heißt die Gewitter nicht mehr ganz so
heftig und auch am Montag ist es dann so
ähnlich damit ein schöner Abend